c'est une affiche à faire pâlir d'envié
tous les programmateurs de festivals
céline dion des rolling stones jennifer
lopez plus de 100 élèves participeront
samedi à oneworld together as khroub
pour soutenir les travailleurs de la
santé cet événement le risque de rester
dans les annales autres autant les raids
avaient marqué la génération mtv je
pense que cet événement loos un peu
l'arrivée de la génération du coup dès
le début des années 70 les artistes se
mobilisent pour la bonne cause à l'appel
de josé risque de radioshack car
plusieurs vedettes de l'époque se
produit sur la scène du madison square
et hyde
on est depuis l unicef pour le
bangladesh mais étant donné que les
médias et à différentes époques dans les
années soixante dix on l'avait pas
encore de deux chaînes d'information
continue y avait pas un petit vie qui
existait je te dirais que le modèle
cancale qu'encore aujourd'hui c'est
celui de live aid en 1985
plus d'un milliard de personnes ont
suivi l'événement pour lutter contre la
famine en ethiopie ce sont des artistes
qui se sont substitués finalement au
gouvernement passe donc oui pour ce live
est très important et beaucoup beaucoup
public que tous les autres concerts à 20
et depuis
lorsque la catastrophe frappe les
artistes se mobilisent
mais après ça a été a calqué on a fait
former pour aider les fermiers aux états
unis on a fait aussi quelques concerts
lors qu'ils étaient un peu pour passer
des messages
je rencontre sont libérés de cette année
là il ya eu aussi un grand concert qui
avait été organisée à 92 à londres pour
un roman japonais majorité tous les
profits ont été versés vos recherches
sur le fil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce méga concerts permettent aux artistes
d'attirer l'attention du grand public
sur des causes qui leur tiennent paca et
les artistes québécois aussi ont emboîté
le pas en soutien aux sinistrés des
inondations du saguenay pour
reconstruire et c'est ce qu'on va faire
ce soir
après la tragédie de lac-mégantic ou en
soutien aux victimes de la fusillade du
métropolis
avec oneworld tigana samedi à partir de
14 heures les plus grandes stars de la
planète nous donne rendez vous en ligne
et entendu une fois de plus prouvé qu'on
peut rendre le monde meilleur avec des
chansons ici nabi alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal